un mes más bajo estado de excepción el
gobierno salvadoreño prorrogó por
segunda vez el mandato que argumentó
bajo el objetivo de combatir a las
pandillas a pesar de las críticas de las
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos la asamblea legislativa
de el salvador aprobó la prórroga con 67
votos a favor y 15 en contra por
supuesto hay que combatir a la
delincuencia
eso hay que hacerlo y de frente y como
se debe hacer
pero no violentando los derechos de
muchos que muy probablemente sean
inocentes y que muy probablemente hayan
entrado vivos al penal y que van a salir
muertos y que no se van a esclarecer las
causas de esas muertes el decreto
aprobado enfatiza que el estado de
excepción ha permitido identificar la
magnitud de la amenaza y grave peligro
que representan para la población
salvadoreña las estructuras criminales y
su particular complejidad realizando
bajo su implementación más de 40.000
capturas
en este sentido human right watch ya se
había pronunciado durante los primeros
30 días del estado de emergencia de
bucle hemos visto evidencia de
detenciones arbitrarias de personas
inocentes
algunas de ellas sometidas a
desapariciones forzadas a corto plazo y
muerte es preocupantes bajo custodia
el régimen de excepción está vigente
desde finales de marzo el mandato
suspende los derechos de asociación
reunión defensa india la habilidad de
las telecomunicaciones y la intervención
de las mismas desde que se aprobó las
fuerzas de seguridad han arrestado a más
de 41 mil 300 personas incluidos 1.190
menores de edad por presunta pertenencia
o colaboración con las pandillas según
muestran cifras oficiales al menos 18
personas habían muerto bajo custodia
policial según grupos de defensores de
derechos humanos